My father taught me many great tips.
*another dramatic intro*
[ Song: Miserere mei, Deus ~Allegri ]
How to be COOL.
How to GET the LADIES.
How to BUILD a WALL!
But most of all, how to run a REAL FUCKING NICE PIMP STUDIO.
PRESENTING: Horny...I mean Hunie Cam Studio.
tnx dad
I may have failed, in my previous EN-DEY-VERS...EN-DEA-VERS...
FUCK YOU!
But this time
I'm going all out
I am creating a new company!
Holy shit what is.... O-O
*gags*
*gags louder*
My new company!
B-3!
Big Bouncy Boobies!
Nikki! You look like you're from Tumblr
*spits* I despise you
I hate your guts *spits*
But business is business
and you're hired, Nikki
Alright, who's got the biggest titties?
Flat chest. Zoey. GET THE FUCK OUT, GET THE FUCK OUT, ZOEY!!
Kyanna!
You got that ass, but get out
Who the fuck do you take me for !?!
We're called the Big Titty Titties!
BELI! You're in
Beli (in-game): Me? I'm kinda nervous ^^
Pewds: Yeah you better be. If you don't perform you're out
Wait you can-?
What?? Why did no one tell me?
You could just hold down the button!
You just have to hold down the button!
I've been clicking like a gazillion times!
Jesus Chri- Thanks for telling me! Thank you so much! (sarcasm)
Okay, we got lail-Lailani
She's asian, fl-
FLAT CHEST?!?!?
LAILANI!!!
WHY DO YOU SHOW UP EVEN?
GET OUT!!
Alright, Zoe- ZOEY!!!!!!!!!!
WE HAD THIS TALK BEFORE!!!!!
I'm hiring Tiffany, 'cause she's my main girl
*kiss* my main boo
After Marzia, of course <.<
It's time to hire another one
Okay, we got Lillian: She's teen, tattoos
Fuck off, fuck off, Lillian!
Why is this so hard!?!
[music] ~Why can't we be friends? Why can't we-~
Aiko. Asian. Glasses.
God fucking- you're dead to me
You're dead to me
Why does she have so many fans?
Oh, glasses...
Oh, they're into glasses...!
Oh....
Uhhhhggn
Big titty glasses company!
Alright, we're hiring her
You better get some implants!
Alright, what's her cup size? B, that's *urgh*
Where are all the big breasted women?
*Kevin MacLeod ~ Local Forecast plays*
///why, yes I did look that up///
Candace....
Finally!
A gift from the gods! Candace!
You're in
Wha- god damn it! Why is it so expensive
to run this business?!
You guys aren't making me money, you're making fucking...
fuck-all worth money. What the fuck!
This pimp business is gonna be the end of me...
Candace (in-game): What's next?
What's next is trying to not get me bankrupt!
Ok we gotta promo glasses
"I love nerd girls"
Yeah, you're into that shit?
I bet you are, ya fucking perv!
We need glasses. Glasses or tits
C'mon glasses or tits...
F' fucks sake, you're all useless
One dollar per hour? Kyanna, you're in
Look how much money I fucking own
while people are at the day spa!
Go have a day at the spa!
while I'm CLICKING AWAY!
Now listen
*water being poured over him while heavily breathing *
God damn, there's so much fucking money involved
I gotta pay the bill somehow
I'm sorry!
Candace (in-game): Hi there! :3
*sighs* Candace...
We're not making the money we need
Go to the hotel, please
Candace (in-game): Leave it to me! :3
Please, and don't contract any STD's, please
[music] ~Why can't we be friends?~
Thank god, Candace. *blow kiss*
Hepatitis...
Candace...
Candace has caught hepati-
Oh! I'm SO disappointed!
I am so disappointed in you, Candace!
*scoffs* Tiffany!
One dollar an hour
Tiffany, you're in!
You're in, now buy me shoes!
My big-breasted glasses girls are so fucking hot
I mean ar- arr- are so good
Candace ran out of steroids *gasp*
Candace is back in business!
What, she still has hepatitis?
What the fuck is wrong with your hepatitis? How do I-
Oh my god, Zoey, how many times do you try?
How many fucking times I gotta tell you, Zoey?!
GET THE FUCK OUT AND STOP WASTING MY TIME
YOU GOT ZERO POTENTIAL, ZERO!!!!
Hey Tiffany, wear this butt plug while you go shopping
Tiffany (in-game): Leave it to me!
Pewds: MHhmmmggggnnnnhhh
BUTTPLUG! Right, Zoey?!?
You wanna work in this business so hard?!
Here, take this BUTTPLUG!
BUY ME SOME CIGARETS
And fuck off!
Here's tits and glasses
That's what they want
and that's what we provide
WHAT? How did she get an STD you wore a condom!!
NO!!
OH GOD I DIDN'T GIVE HER A CONDOM SHE GOT CHLLAMYDIA NOW, FUCK , FUCK!
FUCK FUCK FUCK KILL ME
WHY?!?!?
WHY DOES THIS HAPPEN?!?
Fucking got this shit
I got this shit in the fucking bag
I was born to do this shit
I breathe to do this shit
I live to do this shit
I'm gonna have to hire my last girl, Marlena
Marlena (in-game): Naturally.
Jesus, she's very...
She said naturally, but ain't nothing natural about that, girl
Ooooh my gooood that money!
Big breasted glasses! Best idea I ever had
Finally!
Finally I'm rolling the pimp-business!
Big-breasted glasses was all I ever needed
My mom would be so proud of me if she looked at me right now
The way I handle women with such dignity and respect
Even Tumblr would approve of this video
HAIL TO THE PIMP KING PEWDIEPIE!!!!
PIMP-IEPIE, BITCH!!
THAT'S ME, MOTHERFUC-
What happened?
It stopped...
YES!!!
I finally beat the game!
Finally I did it!!
YES! I am so happy about this!
Big-breasted glasses
That's how it's done
Y'all playa-haters can fuck off
That's how it's done!
Alright, well leave a like if you enjoyed watching this video
Thank you so much for watching and as always...
*blow kiss* to all my hoes...
Call me
*outro*